Okay. Now that I've added onion powder to the recipe, oh,
I have a message from Sarah.
I guess she made a change removing cumin from the chili recipe.
Yeah, I agree, I don't like cumin much.
Sounds good.
Now, I'll go take a look at that.
I'll look at the commit history to see Sarah's change.
Looks like this one.
Now I'll scroll down to see the dif.
And it looks pretty straightforward.
She removed cumin from the ingredients list and
she removed the direction to add cumin.
Since Sarah and
I both modified the same line though, Git is going to mark this as a conflict.
On the next screen,
you'll see some instructions to add Sarah's changes to your own fork.
Then Sarah will go over how I can resolve this conflict.